ich habe letztens im fitnessstudio aus
versehen 30 minuten langen ladies
bereich trainiert bis dann ein trainer
kam und meinte hey wickie hey ich geh
dann mal war auffahrt mann war schluss
mit dem pech hallöchen meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einem
20 fakten über mich video was sich ja
noch nicht irgendwie zweimal gemacht
habe ich habe einfach unter den letzten
fakten videos über mich gesehen dass es
euch interessiert hat was mich
interessiert und begeistert und was ich
mag im leben und ihr noch ein video
davon wollte deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht hey luca du kannst eigentlich
immer so ab und an immer so ein paar
fakten über dich raus hauen wir nun mal
wieder 10 zusammen gesucht hast oder 20
oder so damit ihr ein bisschen was über
mich lernt euch interessiert das ja und
einfach ja vorab noch eine kleine kurze
sache und zwar in englischer youtuber
namens nick eine app herausgebracht die
story das ist in etwa so wie snap chat
nur bei snapshot kann man ja videos zu
seiner story hinzufügen und jeder kann
sich die anschauen
allerdings ist diese story app dafür
geeignet dass man auch videos zu seiner
story hinzufügen kann allerdings können
die viel länger hinzugefügt werden und
man kann sich die nicht nur 24 stunden
anschauen so die besten apps chat
sondern wirklich noch in einem jahr oder
so deswegen wenn ihr bock habt könnt ihr
auf jeden fall mal mir bei story folgen
ich heiße der kontrast dazu noch nix
hochgeladen aber da wird heute das erste
komische spontan wie so fokussiert du
dich denn ihr einfach lust habe dass ich
so ein paar videos aus dem auto mache
oder einfach mal irgendwie hier oder da
dann einfach so ganz spontan total und
professionell mit auf jeden fall folgen
die app heißt ste also sowie story nur
mit ihr am ende ich krieg da nichts für
das die aber wenig möchte nur die app
ist von youtube gemacht und man möchte
sich auseinander als youtube unterstützt
und da ich sehr gerne englische youtuber
schauer und hier rechts schaue ich
gerade ben braun
möchte ich die ganz gerne unterstützen
und wir fangen jetzt an mit fact nummer
eins was mache ich weil ich so will kann
mit feck nummer eins ist ja etwas älter
micro effect serie also auf jeden fall
sache nur eins ist wenn ich irgendwo bin
in einem supermarkt oder in einem
musikladen oder irgendetwas anderem
spiel immer direkt zum verkäufer oder zu
irgendeiner kassiererin oder in dem
typen der darum läuft und frage ihn nach
dem was ich suche also ich gehe nicht
gegen wie einen supermarkt und suche er
ist okay wo steht auf den schildern
irgendwo trost und backwaren oder brote
oder wo kann ich mir jetzt los kaufen
sondern ich gehe wirklich erstmal
kassiererin fragt tschuldigung wissen
sie ihre post ist oder irgendwie so also
ich bin jemand der sich nicht die mühe
macht das selbst suchen sondern immer
irgendwo hingehen und nach drachen
nummer zwei ist ich hab ja relativ viele
stromquellen hier in meinem zimmer also
ich muß sachen betreiben wie
beispielsweise die softbox und gerade im
hintergrund dinge wie gerade mein
mikrofon und mein pc fernseher küche
kühlschrank lampen alles mögliche und
wenn ich schlafen gehe machen es die
meisten menschen er war sogar com
einfach pennen gehn ich mach's
allerdings so ich mache den kompletten
strom aus bis auf kühlschrank und wlan
sonst mache ich bei mir einfach allen
strom aus wenn ich schlafen gehe
drittens ich kann überhaupt nicht bei
sich wiederholenden geräuschen
einschlafen also wenn irgendwie draußen
immer sondern drei sie nicht immer so
eine dumpfe grund lautstärke ist also da
wo ich wohne es halt relativ laut in das
dann immer so ein gewisser grund lärm
der stadt quasi da kann ich natürlich
bei einschlafen oder wenn mein
kühlschrank so ein bisschen
aber wenn ich so etwas höre wie ein
wecker der tick tack tick tack dann kann
ich dabei überhaupt nicht einschlafen
meine mutter hat mir zum abitur
sein wecker geschenkt so drei stück oder
so damit ich auch jahr wach werde weil
wenn man abitur verpennt muss man noch
mal machen und ich hab die alle in den
müll geschmissen vor meinem zimmer weil
ich kann nicht bei sich wiederholenden
geräuschen einfach einschlafens ich
liebe filme über die man extrem viel
nachdenkt also irgendwie sowas wie
interstellar oder vimeo oder inception
oder der banker also ich denke ihr wisst
was ich meine einfach filme die nicht
einfach nur so unterhaltung sind sowie
irgendwie money to jump street oder so
sondern einfach filme in die man
reingeht und dann geht man aus dem kino
raus und denkt noch zwei drei tage über
die story nach oder hier dieser einem
film ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie der
heißt der mit der mit und von von johnny
depp der auch etwas neuere ich weiß
nicht den fand ich auch extrem gut
transzendenz heißt der ausgleich in
letzter zeit links zu meiner spotify
seite und meiner sounds seite immer in
die beschreibungen gepackt hat das
findet ihr jetzt kann auch in der
beschreibung fragen mich immer mehr
leute auf diesen netzwerken hey was ist
eigentlich eine lieblingsmusik klare
richtung et cetera und deswegen hab ich
das jetzt einfach mal mit ran genommen
und zwar meine lieblings jahres also man
kann bei spotify gucken von welchem
genre man die meisten lieder in den
playlisten hat und so das sind bei mir
chicken house uk haus garage house und
future haus also diese etwas oldschool
aber auch future aus der so ein bisschen
neue haus richtung einfach so was in die
richtung nikkei der lehre
jamie oliver helden zu was in die
richtung gleich extrem jahr siebtens ich
liebe flut loops ich glaube dazu muss
ich nicht mehr sagen das war die geilste
hawks achten
ihr werdet mich wahrscheinlich für
verrückt halten aber ich sammle seit
einigen monaten alle rechnungen also
nicht nur die rechnungen die ich für das
finanzamt brauche beispielsweise wenn
ich mit pc kauf oder mikrofon oder so
also für youtube quasi sondern auch
wirklich so sache wenn ich einfach im
kiosk um eine packung kaugummi kaufe
oder im supermarkt und irgendwie zweimal
zwei pizzen kauf oder so ich sammle alle
rechnungen irgendwie weil ich weiß nicht
ich fans extrem interessant wenn ich in
zwei jahren sagen können was an dem tag
gemacht oder hast jetzt de facto bei mir
gekauft das heißt was am tag vorher
feiern oder irgendwie so deswegen also
ich sammle irgendwie alle rechnungen
beim lieblings reales spiel was man
wirklich so spielen kann also in sich am
pc oder an der playstation oder
irgendwas anderes ist looping louie ich
hab da oben auch seine packung looping
nur rumstehen aber ich bin gar nicht zu
voll die einfach zu holen also das ist
ein spiel das wird meistens als
trinkspiel benutzt aber es extrem
interessant könnte ja einfach mal
nachschauen was man damit machen kann
aber dass auf jeden fall mein
lieblingsspiel lienz ich bestelle ca
täglich bei lieferheld also ich bin so
jemand ich habe mein kühlschrank wenn
ich mal so nach schaue er besteht aus
drei flaschen bier vier plätzen und
einer flasche ketchup
münchen pilze sich weiß nicht warum aber
dadurch dass man halt den sommer
großstadt wohnt ist es halt so dass man
um sich herum überall restaurants hat
und man kann einfach berlin verhält
sagen ja ich möchte gern von dem
restaurant ein bisschen was chinesisches
von dem bisschen sushi von denen der
pizza ist es in einer halben stunde hier
und dann habe ich einfach überhaupt
keinen bock einzukaufen selbst zu kochen
bringt sorry falls ich ein bisschen müde
aussehe ich hatte irgendwie vier stunden
schlaf oder oder fünf oder so könnt ihr
auch bei paris doch hier nachschauen
weil ich da bald mein erstes video
hochladen werde aber ich bin auf jeden
fall deswegen meine augen sind bisschen
rot und ich muss auch gleich weg und ich
dachte jetzt einfach ein bisschen real
live videos gibt drei arten von menschen
einmal die die beim regen die es gar
nicht gibt die einfach noch mal rum
laufen dann die zweite die einfach ihre
kapuze aufsetzen und die dritten die mit
dem regenschirm rumlaufen und ich zähle
mich zu den leuten die mit dem
regenschirm rumlaufen als wenn ich
wirklich von mir aus dem oberen
stockwerk runterfahren ich sehr ob es
regnet gleich wieder hoch und wie man
regel schief läuft und ich habe noch
nicht einmal seitdem ich umgezogen bin
meine wäsche hier selbst gewaschen ich
habe
eine waschmaschine oder die spülmaschine
spielt selbst und waschen müsste ich
eigentlich dann in der innenstadt
irgendwo machen es gibt genug
vorstellung meiner nähe
aber da bin ich noch nie darauf
zurückgekommen weil ich einfach angst
habe dass meine klamotten kaputt mache
deswegen habe ich die bisher immer wenn
ich mal nach hause gefahren wird mit
nach hause genommen und die meiner
mutter gegeben um eine komplette sofa
couch auf der ich gerade sitze dass die
hier gerade weht besteht nur aus ein
paar euro paletten und ein paar polz und
die hat mich insgesamt 75 euro gekostet
spreche man mit wenn andere leute die
umgezogen sind so wie ich hier erfahren
und sich eine kutsche 500 euro kaufen
und dann kommen sie zu mir zu sagen sie
hier was die kutsche in virginia tech zu
nehmen das ist einfach nur recycling
sachen quasi einfach eine spedition
gefahren für europaletten geholt und da
fragen mich echt so viele leute nach
also meine komplette couch statt einfach
nur 75 euro gekostet aber es trotzdem
ist ganz bequem eigentlich immer wenn
ich schlafen gehe mache ich nicht nur
die ganzen strom aus sondern ich
schließe mein zimmer ab beziehungsweise
meine wohnung ich weiß nicht warum und
ich weiß nicht ob das normal ist aber
ich weiß also ich fühle mich dann immer
irgendwie sicherer natürlich wenn
irgendwann mal nachts anfängt zu brennen
bin ich am arsch erst mal die tür
abschließen muss aber es ist einfach
seine gewohnheit dass ich das einfach
abschließen wenn ich das bad sauber
mache dann grundsätzlich mit allen
möglichen reinigungsmitteln also ich
weiß nicht was da geb ich glaube es gibt
ab ceraclean irgendwelche scheuermittel
desinfektions reiniger alles möglich ich
nehme einfach alles packt das du drauf
überall auf die stellen sich darüber
alles das ist alles sauber stinkt dann
zwar erstmal zwei tage extremst nach
essig und von frosch ist der glaube
dieser essigreiniger und ich muss
erstmal durch lüften aber wenn nicht
sauber mache dann komplett alter 16 ich
liebe tee und ich hab hier ca irgendwie
da oben im schrank irgendwie zwei
verschiedene tasten 17 verschiedene
teesorten also ich trinke alles mögliche
von scheu über britisch über break first
über schwarzen über über
kräutertee irgendwelche süße sorten über
irgend marcipane husten sollte alles
möglich ich liebe einfach t
stattdessen eigentlich sondern als 16.1
sache irgendwie ich trinke extrem selten
café wenig kaffee trinken oder latte
macchiato und wenn ich überhaupt mal
kaffee trinke dann kaffee schwarz und
dann wirklich nur wenn ich extrem müde
bin aber ich bin absoluter teeliebhaber
17 der sache ist ich habe meine
videoleuchte habe ich mit einem tuch
überklebt wir dass man hier sehen könnt
das ist sondern einfach wischt womit man
eigentlich sauber macht weil wenn ich
das abnehmen würde wenn wir das einfach
viel zu grell und ich habe keinen bock
mehr sonne über zug zu kommen so die 18
der sache ist ich habe vor zwei monaten
das neue assassin's creed geschenkt
bekommen was da oben im regal liegt und
ich habe es bisher nicht einmal
auspacken können weil ich überhaupt
keine zeit dafür hatte also es ist
wirklich so ich komme nach hause geht am
nächsten zur uni wien bis 18 uhr geht
danach eine bibliothek lernen danach wie
youtube videos machen irgendwann
zwischendurch mal essen wenn ich zeit
habe zwei uhr schlafen gehen wieder vier
stunden schlaf bekommen dann wieder
aufstehen und ich möchte einfach so ein
bisschen mehr freizeit dass ich mal
dieses spiel an zocken kann weil ich
darüber bisher nur gutes gehört 19
ich habe letztens im fitnessstudio aus
versehen 30 minuten langen ladies
bereich trainiert bis dann ein trainer
kam und meinte hey wickie hey ich geh
dann mal ganze sache ich bin ein
bisschen und kreativ aber ich werde ihn
genau sechs wochen 19 jahre alt und
gerade deswegen muss sich jetzt beide
geburtstags vorbereitung treffen mit
eifer des videos jetzt vorbei und 20
fakten euch wieder vorgetragen ich hoffe
es hat sich keiner wiederholt mit denen
die ich schon mal irgendwie vorgetragen
habe wenn ihr bock darauf haben dass ich
so was öfters mal hochladen vielleicht
einmal im monat alle zwei monate in
diesem video so zehn fakten über mich 20
fakten über mich wenn ich einfach so im
alltag ein paar sachen raussuchen denke
ja das sind sachen die sind mir nicht zu
nahe privatsphäre aber die können sich
auch ihr euch auf jeden fall noch
anvertrauen ohne das jetzt sagt man war
schloss mit dem patch daran zeigt es mir
einfach mal mit einer bewertung das
wirklich auf jeden fall mega freuen
schreibt mir eure sachen kommentare
eventuell seid ihr genauso drauf dass er
nicht bei wecker einschlafen könnte beim
bäcker einschlafen können aus ihnen
nicht irgendwelche wiederholenden
geräuschen einschlafen können
vielleicht gibt dir selber tee oder
vielleicht habt ihr auch schon beim
ladies bereichen fitness trainieren es
würde mich auf jeden fall freuen wenn
ihr mir das in den kommentaren sagen
würde und ansehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder typisch